[Musique]
j'ai écouté les gens qui demandaient de
l'aide parce que je voulais les sauver
là je me leur est terriblement
contre les forces du mal
ah que la force du mal
je suis tantôt fils
j'ai commis beaucoup d'erreurs et
j'accepte d'en assumer entièrement les
conséquences
la prison m'a changé vous essayez de
dire quoi au juste
je veux passer un accord
fisk prétend avoir changé mais je le
connais mieux que la dernière fois que
nous nous sommes parlés vous m'avez
menacée
et ça je ne pourrai jamais pour le
pardonner je devais arrêter et pour de
bon cette fois il n'y a qu'un moyen de
meute et obstacles mais vous ne ferez
pas vous êtes sûr déçu
c'est bien attention cage de ne pas
prendre la place du monstre j'ai tenté
d'apporter à ces villes la paix et le
progrès
jeudi à un monde entier qui tu es
vraiment quelqu'un qui montre enfin son
véritable visage
parfois si on peut faire le bien il faut
accepter de fer soufre étape
la besoin d'un nouveau méchant mais je
prends bien que je les trouvais cette
armée qui est notre ennemi public
roy
on
nombreux témoins de tous responsables de
cette violente agression n'était autre
que
c'est comme il souligné
tôt ou tard de ville
[Musique]
qui es tu je suis daredevil